welcome back to PEB un sensor Danny
ciani is one of England's greatest rugby
talents playing with England Gloster
bath among others and doing it with such
flare and Brilliant but it was life off
the field but dominated many headlines
his challenges with addictions and
relationships with celebrity girlfriends
put him back on the front pages as much
as rugby put him onto the back ones and
his new book who am I he shares the
truth behind those headlines I'm to I'm
joined by Danny now Danny great to see
you love the book love the honesty love
the fact you just gave yourself as hard
a time as anyone else has ever given you
um but you kind of self- explored at the
same time about who you are and it was
interesting reading it because there's
no I'm not going to compare you to
Russell Brand but I in certain parts of
his story there are parallels one he
rises and becomes this huge sort of
celebrity figure he's a bit of a sex
addict and you talk very openly about
that in your book and the way he talks
about all the women he's sleeping with
and so on may be Unthinkable to a lot of
people to you like yeah I've been there
I've LED that kind of very promiscuous
life just on
that when you come out the other end
after being through that do you ever
look back and do you feel a sense of
Shame about it or do you feel no that
was all part of me being a younger guy
uh I carried a lot of Shame for a while
and and even though you're behaving in a
way which you're trying to gain some
momentary pleasure or some feel within
it to feel good in that moment or or
release yourself from the the chaotic
nature of your mind um that often comes
low and down periods off that as well
and you're then constantly trying to
distract yourselves in other ways I
wouldn't have labeled myself an ad
addict because then that's something
else I've got to get over but I was
definitely always trying to feel better
in some way and I lent into some
substance I lent into frequenting women
in the way I did um but by carrying the
shame when I met my beautiful wife and I
I B all to her and we went through some
tough periods in 12 months because there
was things within me that I held on to
for so long because the nature of my
behavior actually stemm from some form
of pain and I held on to that and I did
feel like I was one of the worst people
in the world and carried all this shame
but when you find someone that sees you
for you and shows you love and I was
able to sit with it and let that melt
away you know I recognize it's just part
of the past interestingly I've talked to
Russell Brand over the years different
times of his life and career and in the
GQ one in 2006 he was his his full
promiscuous boastful worst as many
people would see it very different
character I interviewed later when he
himself got married and then had kids
and so on um certainly abandoned a lot
of that rhetoric and looked like he sort
of grown up for one of a better phrase
but he's now facing trial possibly a
real one but at the moment trial by
media and social media you've been in
that position not quite like he has or
for the same reasons but you've been on
the receiving a lot of judgmental stuff
about you and how you lead your life
what's it like to be in the eye of a TBL
storm yeah so for me the the allegations
weren't as serious as the ones that
Russell a fa it was often judgment on my
behaviors and and you know immature and
and certain things that were behaving in
my life um you know but when you are in
that middle of it and you're trying to
figure out who you are and those are
Snippets of your life that are getting
written about you know it can really
affect you in your psyche um you know
I've lived that through um with Caroline
and everything that happen to judged by
social media judged by how everyone's
going on you know the the the nature of
the media they know what they were doing
in terms of revealing all these
allegations and and now Russell's
getting judged left right and center
from everyone and um you know you can't
condone his behavior do you see
parallels obviously different
circumstances different allegations but
you and I were both talking to Caroline
and you obviously dated her and you were
very close to her closer than I was but
I was trying to help her and give her
some advice behind the scenes in that
last period of her life because I knew
that she was you could tell she was on
the edge you know um and it's very hard
because she's the one on the receiving
end of it and it was it was vicious and
Relentless and it led to the tragic
eventuality of her taking her life when
you see that you look at what's
happening to Russell Brand or we've seen
it with Philip scoffield earlier this
year Hugh Edwards and others do you feel
sympathy for them regardless of the
circumstance they're all separate
instances aren't they they're all
separate cases Caroline was a 5 foot
woman and her boyfriend was 6'5 and he
was well within his right to protect
himself in that fashion and what
transpired there was what happened but
the nature of how the media then turned
on her how they how they turn and they
decide to um create the the the whole
Fanfare around it it does put the
individual Under Pressure but then
ultimately you know we need to wait for
the judicial process we need to wait for
the truth of that but it's already
happened now because social media and
the media and every single news Outlet
is judging and critiquing people uh that
are involved left right and center and
it may be in Russell Bran's case that
it's thoroughly deserved and he turns
out to be this vile sexual predator that
the allegation suggest or it may be that
he's not I just don't think we're quite
there yet because it's it's one version
of events put forward by these women who
should absolutely be listened to and
respected and they should have their say
but he's also entitled to defend himself
if necessary in a court of law for sure
the only thing I can relate to recently
is the excerpts on my book and how
people um took certain Snippets and
created stories on the back of that
but when you read the whole book it's a
very different story in this sense you
know we need to wait for the judicial
process and let that go down the line
because ultimately everyone now has a
judgment on Russell left or right and
it's splitting people it's creating a
real negative sound bite in Our Nation
Tribal isn't it everyone's taking a view
everyone's got to be one side or the
other I'm kind of in the middle right
I'm not defending him but nor am I
saying he should be automatically
canceled from everything because I don't
think we've gone through proper due
process yet yeah you can't condone the
the the allegations whatsoever they're
very serious so it is important that we
let the judicial process go ahead as you
said you have a strange connection not
strange it's a connection but you went
out with Kirsty Gallagher the TV
presenter her sister is married to
Russell BR have you had any contact with
Kirsty about this uh I haven't no um I
met Russell and you know he was a lovely
lovely guy and he obviously turned his
life around but you know at some point
you know uh we need to find out more of
the facts later down the line rather
than trial continue in the fashion that
it is very hard for kirsty's sister I
mean she's pregnant yeah they've already
got two daughters I think very tough for
her isn't it yeah for sure um it's going
to be a tough situation for all involved
you know and and all it's doing is
creating negative sound bites and
negative conversations and and more uh
stuff in the in the media that people
are going to just create more judgment
and more critique on the whole scenario
we need to remember the the victims
involved in allegations that are serious
but we also need to wait for the due
process rather than sitting there
pointing fingers making judgments
because ultimately that's the nature of
the media and what they create soci it's
actually social media is a bigger
problem because everyone's got an
opinion they all want to spew their
opinions they're incredibly judgmental
and there's no real restrictions on what
people can do on social media they can
say what they like I mean I've seen
people say the most terrible things
about people all this year that I've
known a lot of it totally
inaccurate yeah but the soci media
wouldn't kick in if the mainstream media
didn't print the stories in such an
early fashion in the way they have um
you know and it's not this isn't a story
these are people's lives at risk the
victims who are have the allegations are
have been made and also against Russell
so rather than this become Another Story
and Another drama we should wait for the
judicial process and we should wait for
that to play out because people's lives
on both sides are all going to get
affected you were my my kind of
Sportsman you played with Flare you were
different you didn't play by the normal
rule book you got into trouble a few
times you were a bit of a naughty boy
all my favorites right from here and
both of them to Ben Stokes to gazer to
George B whoever it may be I like
Sportsmen that are slightly flawed if if
that's not a disrespectful thing to say
I'm reading your book I just I love the
fact that you you're all those things
but also slightly vulnerable I mean when
you got to the end of the book what did
you feel you learned about yourself
uh for me it was a a very revealing
process of going over times that I you
know the for me the sport part was easy
the training was the fun bit the games
was the fun bit and I F felt very inflow
I felt very in the moment and I could go
and express myself and play at an
extremely high level um but my life off
the field was disrupted a lot in because
of my own upbringing my trauma involved
and everything that I'd been through and
also I was going through life alone I
didn't have much Port of Coe to turn to
um so I was figuring out a lot of things
on my own um so when I I looked back and
went through the whole book and I was
able to share and express from a a
loving place and the wisdom of the
experience um it was really cathartic to
be able to release that because I wasn't
feeling the same constraints or the
confliction that I felt at that point so
it shows that through time and moving on
you can let go and turn your pain into
purpose and turn that into love you wish
you were in the England team playing in
the World Cup uh I I I'm enjoying
watching it I'd always love to be
involved playing at some point but for
me you know I'm I'm enjoying watching it
and I'm enjoying this whole process and
and and everything that's coming my way
well you know Danny a lot of people had
views about you good bad and ugly and
when I read the more negative stuff all
I I judge people how I find them right
you and I have had a lot of of chat over
the years yeah we don't really know each
other but we just have we had various
connections Carolina and others but the
thing that I remember most about you I
had a friend of mine from my Village
called Wayne who had terminal cancer and
he put on a a a day a rugby day to to
raise money for cancer charity and I
just sent you a message say if there's
anything you could offer to for the
auction and you sent a huge bag of stuff
with your shirt your boots some tickets
to games it was a whole load of stuff
just like that and I judge people how I
found him and you're one of the good
guys and he massively appreciated that
and raised a lot of money off the back
of it so thank you for that I've never
had a chance to say it publicly but I
appreciated that and and I love the book
I think the book it's called who am I I
think the answer is you're probably a
bit flawed like all of us but you're
essentially a good bloke and you've
ended up in a good place very much sir
and if if I'd been running the England
Rie team you'd be there in the team I
appreciate dazzling like he always used
to it weren't too bad was it it was
great you were a great player good to
see you cheers and you
mate